populaires. Mais après la ventet
rapidement devenir un
inconvénient.
- Gilles Veilleux adore
l'application OnStar, de GM.
Il peut déverrouiller les portes
de sa Cadillac Escalade,
la démarrer et la géolocaliser
en tout temps. L'été dernier, ie
de vendre sa Cadillac et oublie
l'application.
GILLES VEILLEUX, ancien
propriétaire d'une Cadillac
- Moi, j'ai pensé que rendue
au concessionnaire,
que l'application aurait...
aurait débarqué!
- Par curiosité, il appuie
sur l'icône. L'appli est
toujours active.
- À un moment donné, j'ai cliqué
là-dessus, puis oups!
J'ai retrouvé le véhicule.
Le véhicule, il s'en allait
sur une autoroute direction...
aux États-Unis.
- C'est quand même très
troublant...
- La titulaire de la Chaire
de recherche sur l'intelligence
artificielle responsable,
à l'Université d'Ottawa,
y voit une importante brèche
de sécurité qui peut entraîner
de graves conséquences.
CÉLINE CASTETS-RENARD,
Université d'Ottawa
- Des menaces physiques
ou des menaces de dévoiler
des informations personnelles,
du harcèlement...
- Nous partons à Saint-Louis,
dans le Missouri, à la rencontre
du nouveau propriétaire,
qui ne sait pas que sa vie
privée est compromise.
Nous proposons de faire
une démonstration.
Pouvez-vous le démarrer?
(vrombissement du moteur)
General Motors a refusé
notre demande d'entrevue,
mais nous écrit qu'elle...
Une procédure dictée
dans les conditions
d'utilisation de l'appli OnStar.
- C'est un peu facile de la part
des entreprises, des vendeur
de se déresponsabiliser,
finalement, sur la tête
du consommateur.
- GM ne fait pas bande à part :
d'autres fabricants automobiles
exigent des conditions
d'utilisation similaires
et demandent aux clients
de les prévenir dès qu'il y a
un changement de propriétaire,
une pratique aujourd'hui remise
en question.
Ici Annie Hudon-F